Sure, thanks. And I'm glad to be here.
I really got involved in open source Linux blockchain,
all of these technologies,
all of that, got my start at Georgia Tech.
I enjoyed just surfing what was then
the new internet back in the days of Mosaic 1.0 and before JavaScript,
before mobile apps, before animated web sites.
It was just basic HTML 1.0 and graphics that load really slowly.
And that was the atmosphere that I was raised in at Georgia Tech.
The dorms had just been wired for ethernet,
which was incredibly exciting.
We didn't have to do the slow dial up to connect to Hydra,
the multi CPU computer at the time the Acme Cluster replaced.
And it was an exciting time.
That was ethernet, that was the internet and that was open source.
You could, for the first time,
download software that was not proprietary,
that you could really open up the guts of and explore as much as you wanted.
And so after all my classes were done each day at Tech,
I would go to my dorm.
I was admittedly, did not see the sun often at times.
I spent a lot of time in front of the computer and I was downloading Linux.
I was downloading the GNOME Project.
All of these were the early precursors to what
you see today in Linux data centers and Android,
user interfaces et cetera.
So that self-exploration is what led me to open source.
I started with Linux 0.99
back when Linus Torvalds was still at the University of Helsinki.
Linus, a couple of years before,
in 92 which was my first year at Tech.
Linus had just posted the very first version of Linux and he said,
hey I've got my own version of Unix.
It's kind of like Minix.
Why don't you try it and download it?
And that kick started an open source revolution.
I came into that about a year or two after the initial Linux versions were downloaded.
It was amazing to not just receive a bunch of floppy disks,
which were at the time how you delivered software and load that into your computer,
you had no source code.
It booted up Microsoft DOS or MS Windows 3.1.
And that was it. Open source just blew all that to smithereens.
You could as a software engineer,
open up the car hood,
look inside, understand why it works how it works and then change it.
And the beauty of software and this is why I'm not a mechanical engineer,
this is why I am a computer scientist, is that you can change something,
press a button that says test, and if it explodes, which it usually does on the first try,
You can go back reset to the beginning and try another tweak and do it again.
That's what I love about software.
That rapid iteration process allows you to develop so much more rapid.
And so that open source process led me to Linux and
the open nature of open source meant that this university student could create a patch,
a software change, post it on a mailing list and have
a bunch of other professional software developers critique it,
provide feedback and ultimately integrate that change,
my change as a university student,
into this operating system that everyone uses worldwide.
And that really gives you frankly a little bit of an ego boost.
It gives you, makes you feel good that your change was accepted, reviewed,
welcomed and that peer review process
helps the community adjust to risk and avoid errors.
So that was my journey from the open source that I was coding in my dorm room
led me to Linux and my contributions to Linux as it's the ideal,
sort of meritocracy environment,
the Linux environment as you contribute more
you are trusted more and you learn more and you gain more experience.
And so it's a positive feedback loop whereby as
the years went by I became a better and better Linux developer.
I understood more and more about the hardware process.
I had taken Jim Greenlee's assembly language class
at the College of Computing where I learned MIPS assembly language.
But it was the Linux kernel that really taught me why you do what you do.
Why CPUs are architected as they're architected.
And so that open source process feeds back into other developers as well.
I was able to share that knowledge,
not only with other Georgia Tech students but
with other people in the community and you wind up mentoring,
spreading the knowledge and that led to a career at Red Hat.
Red Hat saw what I had been building,
contributing and they said, "Hey,
do you want to come work for us and build Linux professionally?"
So that Linux, that Linux experience which started in the dorm room,
started with volunteer self-motivated development eventually led to
an over 10-year career and that contribution to open source,
that experience in open source,
also sort of led me to where I am today which is in the blockchain industry,
which is another open source technology as well.
That's right. Late in my Red Hat career, circa 2010,
I was browsing what was a popular web site at the time, slash.org moniker news for
nerds and just basically everyone in the tech community at the time.
Definitely read that website.
It talked about a decentralized digital currency which was
open source and I had experience in distributed computing at the time,
and I had been a skeptic.
I thought to myself,
there's no way this can work.
You've got to have a central cluster of computers.
A central management system of some sort and I was happy to be proven wrong.
I looked at this open source technology and because it was open source,
you can open up the hood inspect the technology gain your own trust in that technology.
And that was my journey from Linux to blockchain,
was that there was a new exciting innovative open source project
which it disrupts the existing business flows,
it breaks new boundaries,
it creates new trust avenues.
And that was very, very exciting.
And so just like 15 years before in my Linux career, it was open source.
I was self-motivated.
I download the source code,
saw some changes that ought to be made.
I thought in my humble opinion.
So I made those changes,
submitted those to the then leader of the project Satoshi Nakamoto,
a pseudonym nobody, mysterious figure,
nobody knows who he really is and he accepted those changes.
So it was just like my first foray into Linux when Linus Torvalds,
the leader of Linux accepted my first patch to the Linux kernel.
It was humbling. It was rewarding.
It was very exciting and it was clearly the cusp of what we now see as
an entire industry, the blockchain industry.
Well, that's the question of the hour and more difficult to answer than you might imagine.
Blockchain is at once a database technology.
It's a technology that has a secure log of changes to a ledger.
It's a distributed network distributes those changes in that database,
that ledger to multiple nodes in a computer network,
all of which are cross checking each other to make sure that that ledger,
that database retains its integrity.
And so this is a very resilient technology, blockchain technology.
If you have a some of those nodes in the network are
malfunctioning then the network is resilient,
it automatically detects and routes around those changes.
And for this reason, it's essentially a reduced trust, very secure database network.
And the reason why that's interesting is that you can use it to deploy
some types of business cases and scenarios which benefit from that reduced trust.
The first use case being bitcoin which is
entirely dependent upon all of the nodes in this computer network.
Arriving at the same answer that Jeff has certain amount of digital currency,
say 100 units of bitcoin and Jeff transfers these to Bob, say 50 units of bitcoin,
this distributed ledger updates my balance
from 100 to 50 and Bob's balance from zero to 50.
Now we can obviously accomplish this with
a centralized database fairly easily and that's what banks do today.
The innovation in blockchain is that you don't necessarily
have to have a centralized authority to execute highly secure database updates.
In this particular case, currency.
The security of a currency is reliant upon this highly secure technology.
And so without that extremely high level of security,
you would not be able to reduce the level of trust required to use the system.
And so this has various cross-border,
cross company, cross organization,
cross business unit type of advantages whereby blockchain is more secure,
therefore you can create connections that can otherwise not be
connected. Well, there's really a lot of potential I think for blockchain in
health care but it is very, very early days.
As we like to say, the software has a lot of rough edges right now.
And so just pragmatically as a business person to a customer,
I would say that the roll-out is going to take several years,
but the potential is that it's worth it.
The potential is, is that we can have a more secure provider licensing,
more secure medical records,
we can utilize associated technologies such as digital identity,
smart contracts, and encryption to really put the patient in control of their own data.
We call that self-sovereign data where you are in control of
your data as a first principle and you permission your medical data to say your provider,
your hospital, your insurance company and
you're the one who is in control of that data permissioning.
And so therefore you're in control as a first pass as to who sees your very,
very private medical data.
And so encryption, a digital identity and anchored in
this very secure database technology blockchain
is absolutely going to make health care more secure,
put the patient in more control as well
as enable what I call gap filling is that today as you,
patients bounce between providers,
as providers bounce from state to state,
there are gaps and records.
And records for example for a provider in
North Carolina might be different from the records for a provider in Georgia,
even though it's the same provider.
It's just a information technology problem,
a data sharing problem that blockchain and some of these cross
organizational technologies really help to solve.
Absolutely. So based on my experience in Linux and I really saw Linux grow up from
a university project to a project that was trusted by startups
to a project that was trusted by
Fortune 500 companies and their data centers of their most critical data.
That flight path was really assisted by in large part Red Hat.
Red Hat took the open source community in one side,
enterprises in the other side.
Normally the open source community doesn't really get along with large business.
They're ideological, they're very have different motivations et cetera.
There are a lot of rough edges professionally.
And on enterprise they don't necessarily understand how to contribute to open source,
how to approach the open source community and how to
capture all that innovation that's coming out of open source.
Red Hat, their core idea was sitting in the middle and speaking
both open source and hacker ease and speaking enterprise on the other side.
And that's really the core vision for block,
is that blockchain has a lot of very fantastic,
very innovative developers with
themselves a bit of rough edges about them and enterprise,
specifically financial services and banks,
they have very, very specific compliance needs.
Risk needs legal needs and you need someone in the middle who can
talk blockchain to enterprise as well as talk blockchain to hackers,
bring the two together and create
a professional risk adjusted product that is essentially enterprise grade blockchain.
So that's what block does is we sell an enterprise blockchain product to small startups,
large enterprises sort of the Red Hat of blockchain.